thank you Dominic wagorn Sky News prime
minister for glassu first of all it does
seem to have been a a lag between
Ukraine asking for more sophisticated
weaponry and it eventually being given
they asked for more advanced artillery
it was eventually sent they've asked for
tanks and they will be sent eventually
they now want fighter jets and we're
training their pilots but we're not
sending the Jets
your predecessor one of your
predecessors a close friend of president
zielinski has has wondered why we're not
doing more why not send more so they can
finish off the job now what is holding
the west back why is there that lag Mr
President good to see you again if I
could ask you about fighter jets how
urgently do you need them and what does
it mean for your country if you don't
get them
so I mean I'll I'll take that that's the
first question and again I probably
slightly the the the notion of the
question because I think we have
continually LED actually in the UK with
the provision of equipment to Ukraine
and whether it was right at the
beginning with anti-tank missiles
whether as you heard from the president
the importance of armored vehicles I
think we've sent hundreds uh whether
it's artillery guns again in the next
few weeks a new set of batteries of our
artillery guns will arrive at tanks
we've already talked about and we're
training combat aircraft for the first
time indeed actually something that we
should have probably been doing a long
time ago because we have a long-standing
training relationship with Ukraine that
predates the war but that is something
as we look forward we'll want to
continue to do more of as we want to
make sure that the Ukrainian armed
forces are trained on NATO standard
equipment and there's greater
interoperability between Ukraine and
NATO which is very much something that
we've been discussing so I think
actually we've continued to be on the
forward Leading Edge of it and we're
providing things as quickly as we can
that the the the Challenger tanks are
going to be on the battlefield as I said
in a matter of weeks I mean you've seen
uh the Ukrainian soldiers are being
trained on them as fast as we can and
we're providing them as fast as we can
and we know that they will they will
make a difference and I think the
president would tell you you know we
we've been having conversations for the
few months that I've had this job and
relatively rapidly after we discuss what
is necessary the Ukraine sees that we do
respond and then we Galvanize others to
respond to that's what we have done and
that's what we'll continue to do
foreign
I would like to be honest with you here
in the history of this war there are
several pages and one of these pages so
effective in a sections it may be in
this war it's been a very special
section uh for um
for our worries and also Great Britain
providing equipment and here we're
talking about German lines as well and
then our people had to rise up and they
had to fight with what they had you know
we are we're not we're not doing any
self-speeding here okay what they had
they were doing and we were just
grateful to for whatever we were getting
and then we turned another page you know
and then we turned into we're we all
turned into fury because
Russians were just killing and murdering
a people and they were raping people and
we were ready to have anything in use
any kind of weapons just to destroy them
and then we turned another page
artillery you know we needed artillery
we
needed to work in a different direction
and this is exactly where we received as
some help and support
for example
in certain places obviously Great
Britain helped us a lot but when it
comes to high Mars we got a lot of help
from the us and we are really grateful
to them for this page in the history of
War
I think it's very important to
understand that Russia has no pity for
their own people they just keep on
throwing their people in to the
battlefield you know we have pity and we
protect our people we would not throw
them just just onto the battlefield we
needed to prepare them
and that that kind of marketed different
stage in the world and now we've come to
kind of this stagnation phase you've
just asked me what would happen if you
don't get this fighter jets or longer
range missiles or we don't have enough
ammunition or because everything
obviously is you know running out and
coming out of maintenance
if you don't have this hundred eight
five artillery you know there will be
stagnation these people will be coming
and be living on our territory and this
will pose great risk to all of the world
because they've just now they've
captured a nuclear station and they just
lived there you know
and this kind of risk will be everywhere
because there are terrorists
and so without the weapons that we are
discussing now and the weapons that we
just discussed with uh
here today and how Britain is going to
help us you know all of this is very
important without this there will be
stagnesh stagnation which will not bring
to anything good